but the main thing in this series is  shooting 53 from the field and then 58  in threes taking four games  the man that's been tutored and mentored  oh Miles Turner bringing that smoke yeah  the fan in the building wants to see a  little more of that  [Applause]  immediately turned into one thing the  man was on him the Corner was open  six-point lead for the Celtics inside  both donovich with a bucket for the  Pacers he's now three of seven for a  total of nine points  the intensity picking up in the last  couple of sequences and Celtics they  read the mismatch every single time  Switzerland an offensive foul against  Brown  keep an eye on this now watch Turner  come flying by his men now oh baby  he's up over the top a little forearm  action there they call that clearing  space  wow he extended Nation